IT GOES FOR TERANCE OW MUCH TIM
HE GOT UP THERE, GAVEGETS THE C
MILLSAP WITH BEMBRY JUST
SHOOTING IT, HE MEMPHIS TIGER.T.
THE BIGGER GUYWANT.
>> Brian: JAXSON HAYES WIDE OPEN
AND MISSES IT.
KAMINSKY, WITH HIM EVERY THE OT.
THAT IS WHAT WE SAW NEW ORLEANS
WITH A HEAVY SPIN AND LOOK AT
THE POWER.
THE CE
HE CAME UP WITH.WASHINGTON.HAND.
A LITTLE BIT STRONG, GREEN.
GOOD PLAY.
PETE 10.
>>
GORDON'S GOT
THAT WASSTUDIO. IT IS GOOD.
A WE HAVE A SHOW HERE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M BASKETESN'T GET.
PORTER STUFFS IT THROUGH.
OFFENSIVE REBOUNDS IN THE LAST
GAMEL'S
PLAYER OF THE YEAR, NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP AT VILLANOVA.
LOOK AT HIM MOVE, FALLING DOWN
JUST THROWS GETS
IT IN AND ANOTHER PA 1 PO AMERI.